[Music]
new game we have a broad spectrum
skaters that she was founded so whatever
type of skiing you want to do you have a
character for that the game itself has
been around for so long that now I'm a
character in it but as a kid I was just
playing it that's cool
when I was growing up in Colombia I
never thought I was gonna be in the Tony
Hawk game scared the year 2012 now I'm
telling you again things like going well
I used to play the games all the time
when I was a kid seeing myself in a game
is it's pretty interesting it's an honor
to be a part of the game Activision
included two girls in this game which is
really exciting
the girls are pushing it you can play
either myself or Leticia she kind of
scares me but we're good friends playing
Tony Hawk's games every time that I've
played the game I wanted to go out and
skate I've been in all the Tony Hawk pro
skater games that makes nine I think my
characters way better skater than me
definitely as a kid I could not even
imagine being in an Tony Hawk game now
kids are gonna play me in the video game
I think it's pretty cool
my parents are really happy for me hey I
was playing Tony Howard games like not
too long ago every time I see him just
so stick means Tony Hawk it's like who's
not gonna be state it's cool to see a
whole evolution of it all
play my dad's game I think it's rad
because it's on such a big scale where
it is now it's pretty insane
[Music]
I really want the game to represent all
of the diversity of skating I feel like
our all-star lineup does that I think
it's it's a really well-rounded crew and
some of the best that's ever been
you